[Music]
the first trailer for marvel's midnight
suns the new tactical rpg from paraxis
the studio who brought us x-com enemy
unknown just dropped and based off of
the game's title and the trailer
marvel's midnight suns is set in the
darker side of the marvel universe
looking to put you face to face against
demonic forces of the underworld as you
team up and live among the midnight suns
earth's last line of defense presented
by marvel's midnight suns
joining me today is creative director at
pharaaxis jake solomon who will
hopefully get me up to speed on when and
where in the vast marvel universe this
takes place what's at stake and most
importantly who is involved jake set the
stage for us what is happening in this
game uh does midnight sons exist in the
same universe as any other part of
marvel just give me the give me the
whole spiel what's going on
the marvel universe is amazing obviously
uh it's been a dream to work there but
the challenge is as you can imagine and
as you kind of alluded to finding your
own corner of that universe and so for
us we drifted to the darker side of
marvel you know the supernatural side of
marvel so the stakes in this game are
all about the supernatural and this um
features one of my favorite comic book
runs which comes from the very early 90s
the rise of the midnight suns which is
set in that sort of very dark
supernatural
part of the marvel universe so that's
kind of exciting for us is that we're
going to be telling a story that people
haven't heard for a very long time with
characters that are probably new to a
lot of players so you've got the better
part of a century worth of marvel lore
to pull from what titles and runs did
you look to most for inspiration
obviously we feature both like really
really popular characters that a lot of
players are gonna know um so you know
you've got your characters like
iron man and captain america and captain
marvel and wolverine but we also really
wanted to feature characters that for us
we want to introduce players to them and
so
you know one of the very first comic
book events that i ever read was called
inferno this was the late 80s again
another like classic supernatural story
in the marvel universe
and that featured this character named
magic and she's this awesome powerful
new mutant who grew up in this hell
dimension called limbo and so that
features very heavily also i think that
the runaways is one of the best books in
marvel history so we have nico from the
runaways as well and so that's again
another character that some players may
not know and that's what we're excited
about as well as robbie reyes ghost
rider and i can't believe i'm saying
this do people not know who blade is is
that possible i mean am i that old but i
don't know is blade like a deep cut at
this point everybody knows blade he's
the you know he's the guy who said the
thing about ice skating uphill that's
right classic yes that's right which i
won't repeat here no this is a family
place uh now speaking of which can you
tell us a little bit about what it's
been like working with marvel games and
sort of how you know firaxis and marvel
got together and what that relationship
has been like working with marvel is is
a dream um but it's just not something
i'd ever considered
and what happened was that marvel
actually reached out to us because a
number of their their games team were
fans of xcom the very first call i had
with the marvel games team um one of
their executive vice presidents of
marvel was on the call and he had very
specific feedback for me about the
finale of the xcom mission and then a
bunch of other people chimed in and they
had all this uh their different
experiences they wanted to share and so
that was really exciting for me because
that meant they knew what kind of games
that we make and so we thought if we can
combine our gameplay experience with the
narrative of all these characters and
their stories that millions of people
around
the world love then it's a match made in
heaven midnight sons has the first
customizable original character in the
form of hunter can you tell us a little
bit about who we are playing as and how
they fit into the marvel universe it was
key for us to tell a new story we wanted
to go to a place that we think a lot of
players haven't seen before in the
marvel universe and a big part of that
for us was not telling a story about any
particular character you're not iron man
in this game you're not blade you can
control those characters but instead we
wanted you to put yourself into the game
and we did that by creating the hunter
which is an all-new superhero that we
designed with marvel which is completely
customizable in terms of how they look
in terms of how they play
which lets the player feel like they're
in the story and lets them feel like
they're experiencing this kind of first
hand and so they are the child of this
ultimate evil named lilith the mother of
demons they're an old character but for
a lot of players it's going to be new
and so we have this relationship between
this ultimate evil and the hunter which
is this new hero we've created which
kind of lets the player feel like
they're in the story themselves was
there a specific character in midnight
sons who you can talk about right now
aside from blade who you're most excited
to sort of uh flesh out in your own in
your own space
the the thing that we're excited about
is there's two fantasies i think if
you're a fan of marvel you love to fight
alongside the heroes and a lot of games
have done that really well
but from the very beginning we were more
excited about this fantasy of well
what's it like to live alongside the
heroes when you read the comics when you
watch the movies i think that that's as
exciting to see how they interact with
each other how you could interact with
them choosing who you want to build
relationships with we have this really
large cast of characters 12 heroes in
addition to the hunter so the player has
to make choices about okay which hero do
i build a relationship with and of
course you get all kinds of gameplay
benefits and cosmetic benefits but it's
really very narrative where you say okay
i'm going to be best friends with these
characters and so for me um i really
like magic
i think that the way that we're doing
some characters like dr strange is very
exciting you know and so it'll be up to
different players like what characters
you love that you know and then you get
drawn into these new characters that
we're introducing like robbie reyes the
new ghost rider nico magic that i think
it's it's just fun every time you play
you know you kind of find yourself drawn
to different characters for different
reasons awesome so whether you're a fan
of the comics or the fan of the movies
this is uh this is a new you know un
untested territory entirely and there's
there's some surprises waiting in store
now you mentioned runaways you mentioned
inferno are there any other marvel
comics that fans should maybe read to
get up to speed with uh midnight suns
well there is the original run i don't i
mean it is when you get in there it's
it's dark and it is heavy and it is all
90s
the original run you know 1991 which
max you were a child for i'm not even
sure you were born then there's lots of
flowing hair you know there are lots of
motorcycles so i would recommend if you
if you really want to learn about this
then read that original spirits of
vengeance run and ghost rider and the
rise of the midnight suns um that we
yeah i think i've even got it got it
here um i own i have mine are like
boarded and packed but yes we have the
uh the classic spirits of vengeance
ghosts try to run from 1991 so
if you're if you're really deep you can
go into that one but i'm just saying you
know beware there's some there's some
dark weird stuff in there awesome that's
music to my ears jake thank you so much
for joining me marvel's midnight sons is
scheduled to release in march 2022
across pc playstation 5 playstation 4
xbox series x and s xbox one and
nintendo switch till then make mine
marvel and for all things marvel be it
games comics movies and so on you are
already in the right place ign enough
said
for over three years fans of zombies
parkour apocalyptic dystopias and games
where your decisions have real
consequences have been if you'll forgive
the pun dying to get their hands on
dying light too finally on track for a
holiday release and to hold you over
until then here is a full breakdown with
tons of brand new info let's take a look
hi everyone my name is timon smachtawa
and i'm the lead game designer at
techland
welcome to the gamescom edition of dying
to know you can watch the previous
episodes of the show on our youtube
channel they reveal many details about
the game and showcase unique gameplay
videos so if you still haven't seen them
you know what to do
last time we showed you the monsters our
special infected enemies so today let's
talk about how to fight them
and not only them but also the other big
threats you will encounter in the world
of dying lights too which are us humans
unfortunately humans tend to be the most
cruel and brutal species out there
especially during an apocalypse
before we talk about fighting let's
start with the basics how do you move
around the city if you watched our
previous episodes you know that a large
portion of the city's population has
changed into monsters roaming the
streets that's why it's extremely
difficult to move around unless you can
run climb raw swing and jump as the best
option to explore the world of dying
light to is
parkour
let's talk about it with my first guest
kat perkovarchuk senior game programmer
casper you are in a team directly
responsible for creating parkour
movement in dying lights too so what can
you tell the gamescom viewers about it
well we're really excited for the
players to see what we've prepared for
them they will finally feel this amazing
freedom of movement in a city built to
support parkour from the ground up even
the highest building is not an obstacle
anymore but a parkour tool to help you
get higher even those familiar with
dying flight one will be pleasantly
surprised because we took all that we
learned from parker and dl1 and built
everything from scratch it's a more
challenging way than to simply upgrade
it but it's more rewarding as well okay
but from my perspective
and i think your perspective as well
creating a realistic movement in an fpp
game is very very difficult and we have
spent a lot of time and resources to
make it physical and exciting at the
same time so how do you feel about it
casper
we really wanted to improve players
perception of their avatar's body and of
what happens to it during parkour
the animators had their hands full but
it definitely makes you feel like a real
tracer
which is a person who professionally
does parkour
it's all thanks to dozens or even
hundreds of new animations it's
especially visible with ropes pipelines
monkey bars etc
with the increased number of animations
players can almost physically feel each
movements while climbing the buildings
it gives them a realistic parkour
experience
and is also surprisingly simple to
master even for beginners the city
allows players to traverse it
effectively as soon as they get there
and their mobility increases more as
they learn new skills
there comes a time when players start
noticing synergies between movements and
that's when the real fun begins you
literally feel like flowing through the
environment they also find out that the
city itself helps them with parkouring
and what might have seen an obstacle at
the beginning becomes an asset once they
learn how to use it
okay but parkour can be more than just
the way to traverse the city
in dying light 2 it's quite handy in
combat too
yes for example i could stun my opponent
with a powerful blow then use elements
of parkour to rebound from him and kick
another one he's also stunned now so i
can rebound from him too by combining
parkour and combat a skillful player can
wreak havoc on both humans and the
infected without even touching the
ground well that sounds amazing so uh
casper thank you for joining us and
thank you for explaining us how the
games parkour system works and i believe
you the same as i just can't wait for
people to see it in action themselves
definitely so thank you once again take
care
so let's talk more about how you can use
parkour not only for traversal but also
for combat and speaking of combat my
next guest is
mad courtois lead technical gameplay
animator
thanks for joining us
i would like to start with something
that was quite difficult for us if you
remember at the very beginning of the
project how to present melee combat in
first person perspective oh i remember
you as you just said creating satisfying
melee combat from a first person
perspective that's a real challenge
that's why we spent many many weeks
iterating it improving it until we got
the right feeling we feel we have
created something special and we're very
excited to discover how how players will
will react to it
so what do you think will excite them
the most
i guess you know we've worked very hard
for our combat to be visceral so we
created many exciting and immersive
elements
such as what we call progressive heat
reactions so it's basically consecutive
hits on enemies will enhance their
reactions they will react differently
based on the the weapon category you're
using based on the body parts you're
targeting so you can stun them you can
trip them over you can cut off the limbs
which might sound pretty terrible but
it's also cool right and it's and it's
also very useful and and and you know
glory
the the direction of your swings also
matters and so does your position
relieve to theirs
we we worked also with the professional
stuntmen to record more more special
more more spectacular uh hit reactions
that was mostly for parkour combat but
also generally speaking to highlight
players power and and to convey as much
as much satisfaction as possible and i
think it's safe to say that immersion is
very important in the world of dying
lights too it's post-apocalypse so it's
very brutal and very demanding so to
survive you really need to step up your
game so
i don't know maybe you have some tips
for the players maybe you think there's
something they should focus on my best
advice would be to be creative
in combat so like you just mentioned
with casper
in dynalite 2 parkour and combat are
very connected they're even intertwined
right allowing players to combine one
with the other very easily very smoothly
so technically you can use the
environment in combat of course as in
kicking an enemy right after a war run
or
even end you can use the enemy to get
somewhere you like so you would just
bolt over them trigger a double jump to
get higher maybe somewhere you had
trouble reaching before but if you want
you can also just land back down trigger
a very powerful attack it's completely
up to you your options are almost
endless that's what we call creative
combat
and to me that would be the best weapon
okay so that's an awesome hint and thank
you for that and thank you for sharing
all of the details
and thank you for joining us
we have used over 3 000 animations of
jumps grips and other parker moves to
create a few dozen skills that can be
mixed and combined so every player can
find her or his own way to survive in
the city in a minute you will see that
in our new gameplay trailer but first
today on
techlandgg.com we have another gift for
you for those who are already exploring
the dying light universe in the first
game we have a unique item the brilliant
hammer a weapon from dying lights 2
which you can use in dying light 1.
go to techland gg and grab it
and if you don't feel like fighting
right now you can get some free posters
wallpapers or even idents special outfit
as you can see it's worth to visit
techlandgg.com but
not at this very moment because now it's
time to watch our new gameplay trailer
here it is
sometimes i wonder what this city looked
like before all this
like many others
people had their ambitions
plans lives
now it's all gone
the virus started
but it was the people who made the world
the way it is
this city
villador
they tell me they had a vision
they had hope
but soon one vision broke into many
different ones
instead of fighting together
people stood against each other
war broke out
was it a little bird
lit a broken leg
hope died
the city is falling
each time we strike down an enemy we
absorb their strength
but i can't let that happen
at least
not
[Music]
the bizarre needs good people
you're doing great so far
[Music]
i have to make a difference
let's check and see
they say that great change is a series
of small gestures
how about this series
[Music]
is all hope
the trailer presented quite a few new
tools of destruction that you will soon
get to use in dying lights too so now
let's talk with the people that are
actually making them marek mushall lead
3d weapon artist hi and shimon straus
the producer of the weapons team hello
the first question maybe tomorrow is
mark can you explain how we as a team
have approached the process of creating
weapons of dying lights too yes we
wanted the weapons to be credible it's
been a long time since the apocalypse
and everything of value has already been
looted
there aren't any stores to buy a new
weapon so you need to build your
equipment from what you find that's why
we had to design dozens of unique
weapons
practically from scratch and actually
that was our design pillar the modern
dark ages absolutely modern dark ages is
this concept of
fallen civilization that moved back
people
nearly to the middle ages
so there are no laws no rules no
technologies that's why our weapons we
try to create them um in a most deadly
and violent way
and working with that concept where did
you get the inspirations from well
citizens of villadore they could you
only use stuff they found in the world
so we thought we should do exactly the
same we scavenge
so mostly we've been looking for our
inspiration in
stores selling agricultural construction
military tools but also at places like
junkyards actually that's true so right
now we've got nearly 200 of them in game
and even though some of them may look
very simple we've got also quite the
opposite like i don't know
semi-automatic crossbow i will love this
one and our weapons are very diverse
visually each one has a unique design
and history just by looking at the
weapon you can tell where the maker fund
departs at a military base a museum
exactly
it's exactly like that in the game when
you pick the weapon you instantly
realize if it was cobbled together in a
street or maybe maybe made by factions
where they have access to welding and
steel cutting equipment yeah and don't
forget about the mods because in dying
like two-state human world if you want
to beat your opponent with highly
effective weapon first of all you need
to find a basic version of that weapon
and then slowly build it up that's what
we call modding we've got many types of
mods like defensive ones let's say
improving quality of your handle or
offensive ones like improving the tip or
the blade itself
so i don't think that right now we would
have time to talk in details about that
but um in december you all be able to
add an effect to your favorite weapons
such as fire freeze electricity ship on
shipment let's stop here let's leave
something for the players to discover so
let's end here and guys thank you for
joining me
before i talk with my last guest i would
like to invite you to participate in our
ugc contest
especially you gamescom viewers we are
waiting for your submissions
and if you are thinking about competing
in the cosplay category you will want to
hear this one let me present to you the
grand jury that will be choosing the
best cosplays of the dying light 2
characters welcome irina meyer lightning
cosplay narga and aoki and engineite and
of course fingers crossed for you our
community let the best cosplay win
check our website for more details
my last guests will explain how the city
itself affects combat and movement
miho doja game designer hello and ana
michaelowski senior game programmer hi
everyone
gentlemen there's this saying that when
you really want to achieve something the
whole world aligns to help you and
basically that's what is happening in
dying glades to stay human exactly based
on the player choices the worth is
literally changing and helping you to
achieve your goals in combat or
exploration
for example the gameplay will be totally
different depending on which factions
you support the survivors or the
peacekeepers okay but can you give us
more detail the differences between the
factions define how each group can help
us
for example the survivors keep to the
roofs and trying to avoid the danger on
the ground
for building they use mostly light
materials like wood or scraps and they
can provide you a various amount of
parkour helpers such as amortizers
trampoline or ziplines this can change
the way how we parkour through the city
on the other hand we have peacekeepers
the post-military guys who literally
keep their feet on the ground
and for building they use totally
different materials
heavy metal objects metal
or even explosives and this can give you
a new combat opportunities like car
bombs
heavy traps or even a new type of a
ranged weapon
yeah and what's important is that we
don't need to remain loyal to just one
faction
the city is divided into several zones
and it's in each of them the players can
decide with whom they want to side
so while progressing through the
storyline you're able to shape the world
to future vision and needs okay but we
know already that humans are active
during the day and monsters come out
during the night but let's reveal more
what are the other differences well
monsters attack mostly in groups and
they instinctively take advantage of the
numbers
so to defend yourself you have to keep
your head on a swivel monsters don't use
special tactics but it doesn't mean they
are easy they push forward so you have
to be clever about getting cornered
and to win you have to stay active move
a lot and learn to abuse their unique
weaknesses
and explosive traps might call me handy
yeah
okay and what about humans
they use increasingly more complex
behaviors as the game progresses
defeating human enemies and monsters
will become more and more challenging
but unlike monsters people cooperate
so while fighting them we need to
closely observe not only individuals but
also the whole group and of course there
are many more unique subtleties to both
humans and monsters
but i think we should let the players
discover them on their own well okay
that's a good idea
but all of that sounds very juicy so
let's end here guys thank you for
joining me
that's almost all for today you learned
a lot about parkour and combat in dying
lights too we showed you that parkour is
not just a tool for exploration but also
an important element of combat you
discovered some of the weapons that you
will soon get to wield and you saw how
choosing a faction may support your
parkour and combat skills
before we end this episode we have one
more special announcement for you dying
light 1 is coming to nintendo switch so
yes it's official now soon you will be
able to play the ultimate open world
zombie game on a new platform and we
know that a lot of you are playing dying
light in june alone the game was played
by close to 2 million gamers big thanks
to our community you're awesome
dying glide 1 for nintendo switch will
be released in platinum edition this is
the most content packed edition we have
ever released on a single playthrough it
contains over 100 hours of gameplay not
mentioning the time you can spend
exploring the world with your friends in
co-op mode
more details are coming soon
if you are hungry for more and you want
to support us why don't you pre-order
the game to explore it on your own in
just a few months
that's all for today thank you gamescom
and see you in the next episodes of
dying to know
we need to take a super short break but
you definitely don't want to go anywhere
because coming up next is awesome indies
a celebration of some of the coolest
weirdest and most ambitious new games
from independent developers